(audience claps and cheers)
- They're very excited.
- I know. Thank you so much.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Welcome back.
- I'm so happy to be back.
- I know, it's been a minute
since you've been here,
but I did, my mom was like
Who did you say hi to when
you were on the Emmys?
And I was like, I don't
even know if you knew,
but I just saw you and I was like, Oh hey.
But you were in white
- [Kelly] right?
- [Selena Gomez] yes
- [Kelly] You didn't even know.
But I was just like, I just
looked out and I just saw you.
And I was like, well, I guess I'll say hi.
- [Selena] Well why you didn't you say hi?
(audience laughter) You
want to know what though
- I walked in and out.
I literally walked on
stage and walked out.
- My dress was actually
riding up the entire time
(audience laughs)
so a lot of people saw
something they didn't wanna see
so I'm so sorry
- Ha ha ha ha. I didn't,
I was, I was on stage.
I literally walked out to present an award
and I had come from another job.
So I literally walked in
the building and walked
on the stage to an award and I was like,
Oh, there she is and you
look so you were so radiant
like in that white dress,
It was so beautiful.
- [Selena] Thank you so much.
- [Kelly] Yeah. You like stuck out to me.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] But you've had a
big life change since then.
You turned 30, right?
- Yes.
- That's awesome.
Was it a fun party? Did
you plan a big thing?
- Yeah I never throw myself
parties and I thought I should.
Right. Cause it's 30.
= [Kelly] 30 yeah.
- And I fully enjoyed it
but I think I've been
really enjoying the process
of being 30 and you know
learning to put up with things that I can
and just caring about who,
who I surround myself with.
It's been kind of a journey.
- [Kelly] 100%. Pick the
weeds, keep the flowers.
- [Selena] Yes.
- [Kelly] That's what I say.
I feel like too also,
and I, I found myself
say I watched your documentary
with my mom and my sister.
- Aw
- And we were, they're
visiting and I was like
Oh I wanna watch this thing.
I was like, she's coming on.
Watching that, it reminded
me of several relationships
and friendships in my life.
And I feel like friendships have seasons,
- [Selena] Yes
- And that's not a bad thing.
I feel like people can come
in and out of your life
at different times and I, I felt like
do you feel similar to that?
- [Selena] Yeah, there
actually, I mean we started
shooting this in 2016 and there are people
in that doc that are no
longer in my life because that
- [Kelly] Yeah
- because that was the right thing to do.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
And, and not necessarily
a bad thing either way.
I always feel like it's
one of those things where
it's like we're all on different
like paths and it's okay
that we didn't meet up right now.
- [Selena] Yeah.
- Cuz we might meet up again later.
- Yeah. Or not
- [Kelly] Yeah. Or not. Or not.
No, I have those things too
where it's like you don't
realize that's, I think
was so trigger cuz my mom
and sister were just like,
wow, you two are similar
And I was like, okay. (audience laughter)
Um, I was like loud and clear.
Um, but it was, it was
just one of those things
that I thought I think
when people watch this,
they're gonna feel like
a big sister with you.
Like, and be like, wait,
wait, you wanna just hold you
and you wanna cuddle cuz you're very open
about everything in the documentary
about your health, about
the highs and lows.
It's not like some depressing,
it's a lot of things
all the emotions.
But I thought that it was really
cool that you were so open
about, I mean, having lupus
about bipolar disorder
about going to speak.
What was that like
- That was amazing
- [Kelly] Speaking at the hospital
I went to the McLean Hospital
and it's one of the
best hospitals for all.
I mean they are, they're
kind of covering everything
in the mental health space.
And so I, I was able to
say my diagnosis out loud
for the first time and
- [Kelly] yeah,
it just it gave me such strength
and it really, it wasn't easy
and I think that's why
I wanted the documentary
to feel really personal.
But I'm got, I'm kind of scared like a lot
of people are gonna see
this whole other side
of me and I'm like, hope they like it.
- I think it's refreshing.
I think it's nice cuz it's
such a filtered world.
Like, and we're different generations
so it's just like, it's, I
feel like your age and younger
like it's just such a,
a different world where
everybody filters everything
online and and that's not live.
That's not real life.
Like everybody has things, right?
- [Selena] Yes.
- And I just thought it was very powerful
like to not know what
was happening with you
but you knew something was wrong.
You sought out help and
you got it and that's
that's gonna help so many
people that watch this.
- [Selena] I hope so.
- Yes. Whether it's depression
or whatever, anxiety, like whatever.
It's like it really does.
You watch it and you go, okay
wait, I do vibe with that.
Like that's similar to me.
So it's, it's gonna I think
awaken a lot of people.
- I hope so. Cause I'm really nervous.
- [Kelly] Was it nervous
for you cause in the
in right after you spoke at that hospital
all those people like
afterwards like talking to you
- [Selena] Mm hmm
- Do you ever feel the weight of that?
Like when they're telling you their story?
Cause I feel like a lot
of people will tell us
things that maybe they
should like someone that's trained
- [Selena] Yeah, exactly
- That knows what to say back. Yeah.
Do you ever feel the weight?
- Well I'm definitely not a professional
but it was really, I
think I'm more so connect
with people that have
been on a similar journey
and I don't mind having those
conversations with people.
Again, I, anything that I do
I want it to be some sort
of light in the world, so
- Yeah
- I'm excited that people
will get to see, you know
how how much it paid off
to be honest with my story.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Cuz it's freeing.
It feels freeing when you're
finally like, nope, this is me
and this is how it is.
- [Selena] Yes
- I loved how you were in Kenya.
Like I loved how it was, it
was different to watch you
and even having conversations
with these girls and
like your many revelations
like with these girls
like ask about guys that one conversation.
- Yes.
- What was her name?
- Betty.
- And she is unbelievable.
And I basically went on
a trip and we were there
with an organization but this
young woman who was younger
than me just spoke so candidly
about her own mental health struggles
and it was really incredible
to be all the way aside
on the other side of the world and
and see how people handle
these things and how, you know
people don't talk about it
but she was just so beautiful
and her stories really great
if you do get to watch it, it's beautiful.
- Yeah, I loved, I loved that conversation
at the table and everybody,
it was just nice to
see you that moment and I
thought that was really cool.
(audience cheers)
- So that was a look at her new
documentary on Apple TV plus
Selena Gomez. My Mind and Me.
You also have a lot of joyous
moments in the movie as well.
So what are some of your favorites?
- Well essentially the, the
whole documentary is a bit
on the serious side because
I discuss my bipolar
and I discuss the highs
and the lows and then
you see when I actually
didn't know what was going on.
But I think the best part was, you know
I got to show my friendships.
I got to show a little bit about how
I can turn something into, you know
a situation like being in the hospital.
I wanna turn that into something that I
- Learned.
- [Selena] Find a positive.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And like I loved the
nurses there and you know
it was little jokes like I
couldn't get the the straw
out cause I put me on meds and I was like
- I know.
And you kept right, right
- I was like so sleepy. Thank you.
Yeah. But it's just, yeah,
it's very honest take
on someone who has to live
with all of these things.
But I mean the whole point hopefully is
at the end you're like, well cool
she's gonna go live her
life and do her thing.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Cause I'm never gonna
make one of these again.
- [Kelly] I know. Well and
that's my, is it hard, like
cause people are always asking
me to like, do something that
or like write a book or
something and I'm always like
Oh God yeah I already
lived it the one time.
Like, I don't know if I wanna revisit.
Was that hard revisiting?
- It was, I mean I've only
actually seen the film
I was in the editing process
but I've only seen the film
all the way through one time
and it is very triggering so
- [Kelly] yeah,
- I don't plan on watching it ever again,
but I think I really
want it to be something
that affects people in a
good way or you know whatever
- [Kelly] It's almost
for other people too.
- That's what I hope it is.
- Yeah.
- I hope I'm turning
this into a good message
and not making it about me.
- [kelly] No, it's cool is
I love anything that I watch
and then the people watching with me
we ended up having like an
hour discussion afterwards.
- Oh that's so great.
- Yeah, it's that I
think that's really good.
I think people need to talk more.
- I hope so.
- [Kelly] Yeah. I've, I find
out what I'm feeling when
I'm writing sometimes
like I have a, that's why
I started writing is my mom
was like, you're just a bottle.
Like just get it out on paper.
So do you feel like you do that?
Like when you, sometimes
when I write a song I'm like
well damn, I didn't know I was that angry
or I didn't know I was that sad about it
or I didn't know, I didn't
know like the depth of it.
- [Selena] Yeah.
- Do you do that?
- I do, but you know
what's funny is I equally
I get the the point where I'm like,
nothing's going on in my life.
I don't have any drama.
Should I make some drama for music?
- [Kelly] Should I create chaos
- [Selena] So equally been
those moments where you know,
you're there and there is
so much goodness going on
and you try to figure out how to channel
all of those mixed feelings.
It's the best therapy honestly.
- I know.
That's why I always
write better when I'm sad
or going through something.
- [Selena] Yeah.
- Because I know that
sounds sad but it's just
it's a tool for me.
That's how it started before
I even was a singer, so,
Oh well we're all a little messed up.
So you're on Only Murders in the Building.
- [Selena] Yes.
- [Kelly] I love this with
Steve Martin and Martin Short.
(audience cheers)
Yes. So it's so good.
So what's it been like working with them?
It's such an odd like pairing.
- [Selena] It's so odd. It's so weird.
You know, I'm, I, my,
my whole day consists
of listening to 70 year olds
talk about news or who's like
or Steve is like, who's a Dua Lipa?
And I was like, no, (audience
laughter) it's not a thing.
It's a and and they're just
so much fun to be around.
They're hilarious, they're
pure and they're professional
and they just, they keep
me wanting to be better.
- [Kelly] Oh that's cool.
Yes. And it cool how life
works like that you didn't
think you'd be doing
something and then all of a
sudden you're doing this
and you're surrounded
by people you'd never
would've been surrounded
- Never
- And it kind of brings
out the best version
of you that the people who we should
surround ourselves with
- That's right.
- Yep.
I'd rather hang out with them.
- [Kelly] Yeah. It's hard.
Well it's nice too cause
they've been here for a minute.
- [Selena] Yeah.
- So sometimes it's nice
to just shut up and listen
and be like, what can you teach me?
Cause I'll take it.
- [Selena] Definitely.
- [Kelly] I love that.
Well one of your goals now
is to get therapy taught
to school kids, like
while they're in school
and I think you got this all
the way to the White House.
The White House stepped into this.
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Right?
- [Kelly] How did, how did,
cause I remember you talking
in Kenya and the thing you were like,
I really wanna do this.
I don't know how to implement.
And I think it's cool
cause you did implement
something you wanted to do
with Dr. Biden.
- [Selena] Yeah, hopefully
that is just the beginning.
I think for me, I learned
so much in the process
and there's this behavior therapy called
dialectical behavior therapy
and I think it's, you know,
it sounds boring, but it is
it is a program that helps
you understand your emotions
and wise mind and all
these different things
that you're kind of walking through.
And I just figured when
you're young and you're
in school, they, they say,
Are you happy face today?
Are you sad face?
And I feel like they
should just keep that going
into others, to other grades and yeah.
And I just feel like it's,
it's a necessity just
like physical activity
is and everything else.
It would be, I think
it would be amazing if
if I could make it happen.
- Yeah.
- That's not wood.
- No. I will say, this is
wood I knocked for you.
I think it's, it's crazy
cool too because my daughter
she's in second grade this year
and she came home and my son Remy was like
he was having a hard time with something
and she goes, oh buddy
you know what they have this, this woman
I can't remember her name, but there's two
of them and if you ever, if
you have a hard time with that
you can go talk to them about it.
So anytime And I was
just like, I, I tears.
- That's so good
- So I was just like, I'm
doing good at something.
I was like, I was like
because it's so cool that
the school's implementing
that because to have a kid going
through a lot of things
and being a kid is hard.
- Yes.
- I think what you're
doing is, is perfect and
and important because to teach kids
at a young age that mental
health is so important
and that's why we're still
talking about and still going
through these routines is so
important because I think a lot
of people would be better off as adults.
So thank you.
- [Selena] Thank you
- [Kelly] I think it's
really worth fighting for.
- Thank you.
- Yeah. I think it's worth fighting
for and using your platform.